good morning rich anything you doing
alright man good have you ever had like
a sports dream yeah I dreamt actually
last summer that that Dan Quinn hired me
to be an assistant for the Falcons we
saw what happened after that they made
it to the big game and I guess that's
the rest of the story I'd like to tell
it happened last year I don't know what
that meant this is after they lost the
Super Bowl no this was the summer before
their Co that was two summers ago yeah
maybe you know I've convinced them to
take a knee and get a field goal and
then win the Super Bowl
yeah maybe my clock management skills
would have come in handy you know but
alas real real real life took place and
I was busy that night and I'm sure coach
was too but they're you I don't know
what this means for you it's it that
sounded like one of the worst
pharmaceutical commercials I've ever
seen like you have to consult your
doctor to see if Redick is right for you
damn I don't know that could be it right
there careful before taking Redick yeah
if Redick lasts longer than four hours
consulting so we get a coaches we get we
getting into must-win situation for
Jason Garrett nut I'm talking about
overall picture Jason guard do you think
that there's any chance Jason Garrett is
coaching for his job these next five
games man I can't read Jerry Jones's
mind it really honestly depends on if I
guess Gruden would be interested I mean
that's the whole thing I mean as you
know Jerry likes to make big plays and
would Gruden come out of a Monday night
booth to coordinate the you know offense
for DAC is DAC the kid that he would he
would you would you know hitch his wagon
to for a decade to come with Zeke and
Dallas and get a ton of money you'd work
at this building that I'm standing in
right now by the way you could hear the
hum of the tractors brushing the field
of the rubber pal
right now tonight yeah by the way how
was that for a word picture well I liked
it I love you think about that oh I know
you what's on the jumbotron right now
zero it's freaking me out
it's a huge dark black screen right now
it's and is building something else man
I mean it really is a wonder of the
world it were you walk in here you just
your your senses are just uh
you know don't know where to go but
anyway tonight tonight is a big one
obviously I fear the Cowboys are going
to go over Zeke I really do hmm their
first three games without them they
haven't scored ten points yet it's the
the the last team to go four in a row
without scoring ten points Roe was the
the Oh three Giants and I think that
that's a possibility again tonight the
Redskins defenses is a very good squad
that we've seen play against some
top-notch teams I know that they folded
in New Orleans a couple of weeks ago but
what they did in in Seattle what they've
done on Monday Night Football
they were one of the first teams to
expose the Raiders this year and and I
really liked them tonight a lot Kirk
Cousins like this building Ditka
touchdowns no interceptions six hundred
yards combined and his last two starts
here tonight as a rough one for for
Dallas and then you know the next one is
that the Giants and who the heck knows
what scientists they're gonna look in
seed hair I mean that one's a total
toss-up you know before they go to the
black hole and then he comes back so I
don't know if he's coaching for his job
to answer the question that you posed
because I don't can't read Jerry's mind
but the last five games is going to be
interesting regardless your reaction to
what happened with Eli Manning as well I
done I'm stunned I know the Giants are
gonna have to figure out what the Eli
Manning end game is at some point I
honestly didn't think now would be the
time to figure it out I that a you know
though and that there's an owner in John
Merrow
who is one of the most whip-smart guys
I've ever met in the 14
years that I've had done this and
knowing him and knowing the traditions
of this team having grown up in the New
York City area
you know I'm flap I'm really stunned
that they would have an organizational
meeting for an all-time quarterback like
Eli with two rings a Walter Payton Man
of the Year resume and a streak a 210
game streak that that can't be trifled
with and that they would break that
organizational meeting thinking that a
start you you know you can start let's
check that box for you but we don't know
how long you're going to start because
we do need to see these guys in the game
essentially telling Eli Manning and then
the rest of the Giants and the fan base
that they're going to treat the last
five games like a preseason game just
trying to see what they have in in their
other two quarterbacks and then to make
this maneuver and then uses their
frontman a guy who has zero credibility
in that channel right now in Ben McAdoo
and have him
bust out the old saw of we're doing this
to win this week and then the
quarterback that they choose isn't the
youngster that they do need to see if
he's got something you know on the ball
before they choose but they choose the
guy who the entire city is at a front
row seat to the most bizarre struggles a
starting quarterback has had in the NFL
over five years from from high quality
starts for the Jets to having his jaw
broken so Geno Smith is the first guy
they go to it's just so remarkably
tone-deaf on so many levels
I can't understand it I just can't start
your weekend early Thursday Night
Football it'll be the Redskins taking on
the Cowboys coverage begins at 7:30
Eastern on NFL Network and NBC Hope home
of Super Bowl 50 to do you think I don't
think Ben McAdoo's back next year but do
you think Eli Manning yeah do you think
he'll eyes going to yeah I do
I mean how do you how do you put it back
together because if you're going further
for the Giants here's the thing I you
know I don't know who they would hire
you're gonna have to try and hire
somebody that that gets the fan base on
board right so it's gonna have to be a
big-name guy why would somebody come in
and say okay my first two years of my
job is gonna figure out what what blew
up in Ben McAdoo's face is what to do
with Eli Manning what he's done right I
mean I I don't know who would take that
job under those circumstances so
whoever's coming in has got to start
completely fresh with whoever they will
draft at the top of next year's draft or
Davis web and the interesting thing is
they do have a five-game schedule but if
you want to see what Davis Webb is made
of every single NFC East opponent that
they have is coming into their house
over the last five games yeah
so you could see you could see what the
future looks like with this kid the
problem is they don't have any running
game and they don't have any wide
receivers and they don't have any
offensive line which is kind of why a
lie looks like a two and nine
quarterback yeah I wonder if someone
like Josh McDaniels and maybe Scott
Pioli who's Bill Parcells son-in-law
maybe you know you got you did and I
know nothing about this I'm just
throwing out maybe that possibility of
Pio ly working with the Patriots and
Josh McDaniels and maybe you have you
know something like that an
infrastructure that you don't you can
trust but I do think you have to start
over who if I'm coming into that job I
don't want a 37 year old soon to be 38
year old Eli Manning exactly look I'm
not saying that the Giants are still a
highly attractive job in an organization
despite what we're seeing play out right
now and despite what we're seeing play
out right now
you know Eli and the Giants are gonna
have a relationship for decades to come
you know no NFL divorce has been ugly
was uglier than Favre in the Packers and
they're living happily ever after right
now so no matter how bad it is the
Giants I am let's put 99.9 percent
certain they're gonna make it right in
the long run yeah but right now I do not
see Eli Manning starting for the Giants
next year although he could start over
the next five weeks because the last
time Geno Smith got this opportunity
because the quarterback in front of him
was benched he blew out his knee within
the first half and Ryan Pitts
Patrick was right back in there so and
if he lies the back on Dan I'm gonna put
in here but in his ear they're gonna
make him get on a plane Oakland after
running stop team practice and put an
ear but in his ear you should tell them
go home your wife and kids
go home your wife and kids your if you
want to run please be around a team but
we're not gonna make you stand there and
be a backup it's gonna be so humiliating
in the world I honestly just cannot
believe it
that this is the way it's playing out
and that again a guy who everybody in
New York New Jersey Connecticut all
believe isn't going to be back next year
the one who's the face front now I know
John Mara did speak to the media yes
yesterday but I I you know this is just
an awkward five-week period that I think
the Giants just need to get through and
hit a reset button because I saw
everything
well I'm radio only today inside AT&T
Stadium so Brad shams gonna join me to
voice the Cowboys and Chris Cooley who's
part of the Redskins broadcast and and
off we go just talk football for three
hours we'll be watching tonight you know
I watch on Sunday morning I'm watching
tonight you're gonna be with Rodney and
Tony so you know yeah is there anything
I should say to them no I know you'll
see them Sunday again er no I I'm fine
with them seeing another anchor behind
my back I'm okay with that okay I'm okay
don't worry Dan I okay have fun got it
thank you
that's Rich Eisen NFL Network for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
you